and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 135 today
we're gonna talk about mementos
now Ryan if this was a regular podcast
this is exactly where the advertisements
would go this would be our advertisement
for Mentos - yes I hit us up in the DMS
mementos I mean Mentos I love Mentos
just so we can laugh at you you know I
would just say going over these
questions man I feel like almost this
podcast could have been called like the
rules we build around ourselves or
boundaries or something because I found
myself with all of these questions kind
of looking at what are the boundaries
that people set up when it comes to
mementos and what what are these like
sort of self constructed prisons that
we've made yeah and it's all decorated
by all of these sort of tchotchkes and
what's a tchotchke to me might be a
precious item to someone else absolutely
I think we'll dive into that today but
first a little bit of follow up your
added value from last week yes what was
it it was evil genius Beck's and I
started watching we saw the first oh
yeah and how do you think I'm hooked I
mean it vexes is not here right now
she'll be back in a couple days with
Ella and so I got to find a way to and
we don't have any time to watch TV
usually but whenever I could sneak an
hour in that's that's where I'm gonna be
going unless it's basketball well yeah
so you know what she's leading the as of
race as of this recording sadly very
sadly it is the Golden State Warriors
are up to 0 although Cavaliers should
have won the first game there was Junior
Smith like he JR Smith the game he
thought they were winning and so he like
ran away with the ball but they were
actually tied and so I went to overtime
and they got this job anyway well we'll
skip the basketball talk this week I
just wanted to say the evil genius is
really good so far
hopefully it results no spoilers no no
no I just that first episode
would all that first episode all it does
as it gives you about 20 questions yes
so many questions that you need answered
and it does answer all the questions in
the next 500 ah that's good there's six
episodes total I think so holy moly
okay well I'll strap in for the ride and
then last week we talked about tickets
are now on sale for the simply southern
tour but we have all the guests to
announce so I figured at the top of the
show we get at least tell people about
the folks that who are going to be on
this tour with us really we're gonna be
talking about money and minimalism yeah
this is I mean it's a simply southern
tour because we're gonna be in the
southern states but but man we've got
some awesome guests we're gonna help
people with whether it's budgeting or
making better money decisions or
building habits around money all three
of our guests are gonna speak directly
towards that and I think it's gonna be a
great torment yeah so we're gonna talk
about debt we'll talk about finance
let's talk about money and budgeting and
saving and retirement and it's really
because we have some good answers on
those topics but we wanted to say why
don't we bring some experts on well it's
about it I'll be honest man like most of
my answers I get from people like this
in fact you know Rachael Cruz who's
gonna be one of our guests
yeah hurt her father Dave Ramsey I mean
all of my financial advice that I give
to my mentor students it usually comes
from Dave Ramsey yeah yeah and so so
let's just talk about it real quick
we're gonna be in Birmingham on July
20th now here's here's the deal I think
all three of these events will sell out
but we're gonna have a lot of people who
actually show up to all three events
because all three events are going to be
different it's not going to be like with
the lessons now to where every event was
pretty much the same I mean questions
are obviously different when people come
up and asked every question but we were
giving a talk then this is gonna be
different because instead we're bringing
on a guest we're gonna talk to them
about their experience with money so in
Birmingham on July 20th we're gonna be
with Anthony O'Neill and you might know
him as the author of five mistakes you
can't afford to make in college and
here's a quick bio about Anthony at age
19 he was deep in debt and short on hope
with no direction of where his life was
headed but after hitting rock bottom he
turned his life around and committed to
helping young people cultivate their
passions since 2003 Anthony has helped
thousands of students succeed with money
in their
and personal lives so if you want to say
hi to him you can say him on Twitter
we'll put a link to his Twitter in the
show notes it's at Anthony O'Neill and
what I like about this is the money that
I'm sorry the device about money that is
good for young people tends to be advice
that you can also extrapolate out and
apply to the rest of your life like oh
yeah the things that I apply to my life
right now at age 36 I really wish I
would have applied when I was college
age right I was eighteen nineteen twenty
twenty-one and here's this book if
you're watching this on I don't know if
we're actually about the YouTube version
of this but podcast Sean is recording
this podcast on video for the YouTube
channel youtube.com slash the minimalist
but his book five mistakes you can't
afford to make in college well what
we'll be talking about some of the stuff
that he talks about in here and then in
Louisville on the 22nd of July we're
gonna have chris hogan with us so you
probably know chris hogan he has a great
podcast called retire inspired so it's
the retiring inspired podcast which is
also the name of his book which i have a
copy of right here and so you probably
know chris talks about retirement but
again it's not about like once you're in
retirement this is advice for you know
that's a terrible time to plan for
retirement when you're all retired right
it's when you're our age where your 20s
30s 40s 50s do i keep spitting on dude
you've got the spittle is like it's
flowin today man i am honored i've you
know how many i know be prepared for the
video pod kenny men and women would just
kill to be right here right now getting
spittle thrown all over them
none I mean now I'm not one of them but
you're very empathetic yes yeah you can
identify with those people I know but
Chris Hogan's gonna be with us
Louisville July 22nd you can say hi to
Chris on Twitter he's at chris hogan 360
on twitter and then of course rachel
cruise he mentioned she'll be with us in
nashville on July 24th she is the
best-selling author of three books one
of them I have here which is love your
life not theirs that is her newest book
she's also on the Rachael Cruz show that
was she just launched and
the whole reason for the stores we're
gonna be guests on on her show so we
said hey if we're gonna go down
Nashville to be a guest on her show why
not set up three events are sort of in
the South Birmingham Louisville and in
Nashville right around this and then if
we're gonna be in the south already why
not ask the folks from Ramsey solutions
to give some advice about money right
well you know it's funny I mean I don't
know if that's what your what your aim
is right now but by explaining how this
came about that's usually how most of
our tours kind of come about right it's
like oh we get asked to do one or two
things and then we're like we'll shoot
if we're gonna be traveling and we're
gonna be on that side of the world or
that side of the country we might as
well throw in a few other events so yeah
that's exactly how this came about man
I'm I'm so excited you probably also
know her from her book the she wrote
co-authored with her father Dave Ramsey
it's called smart money smart kids so on
this tour we're gonna talk about
retirement we're gonna talk about family
and money we're also gonna talk about
minimalism and decluttering and letting
go as well we'll be answering your
questions we'll have conversations with
our guests coming out Birmingham
Louisville or Nashville you can go to
the minimalists com to find tickets
right now I what else I got follow up
here Oh since we were talking about
acquaintances last time and friends and
relationships yeah I wish I would have
had this article from Fast Company
because I think it's really good advice
now I'd like to append it a little bit I
like to talk to you about this article
it's called the science of why we talk
too much
hmm and how the shut up man this is some
advice I could certainly intake well and
let's talk about that so the the
subtitle of this is our brains are wired
to reward us for talking about ourselves
but droning on about yourself is a
horrible way to make a good impression
and I would just say it's a horrible way
to make friends you know to make
meaningful relationships to just drone
on and on about ourselves dude can I
tell you like and I'm guilty of doing
this but one of the one of the things
that I don't want to say like makes me
not want to be friends with someone but
it turns me off from the conversation or
from an interaction is when I'm meeting
someone for the first time and I'm
telling them like a story about like
whatever it may be and then your trip to
Cancun yeah my trip to Cancun the
and they're just trying to connect yes
like they're not trying to do anything
mean right but it's like they'll cut me
off and then they'll tell me about the
French trip to Cancun and like not let
me finish my story like I don't know why
but this happens to me a lot but I'm
also guilty of doing that sometimes
right but it's but just here to this
article's point of yes like talking
about yourself especially interrupting
someone while they're talking about
their self to talk about yourself yeah
not a good way to make friends yeah not
a good way to make a first impression or
a lasting well you can make a first
impression it's not a good first
impression right yeah so here's I'll
read a bit of an expert then we have a
discussion around a Ryan you probably
talk too much and there was a good
reason for that science says that humans
being social animals are programmed to
use communication as a vital tool to
survive and thrive this wouldn't be a
problem except for the fact that science
also tells us that our favorite subject
to discuss is ourselves
people spend 60% of their conversations
talking about themselves 80% when
chatting on social media so there's a
nice disparity there think about that
Wow and it's it's one of the reasons
that I make sure that when I'm when I
tend to write anything that has to do
with advice I'm writing usually in the
the plural third person I'm writing
about we here's our problem as consumers
or our problems as human beings or
whatever as opposed saying you you you
you blaming other people right we're
saying me me me me look how great I am
me me me me me but here's our problem
here's how we can fix it right and then
of course I'll often tell it through my
own lens like like here's the story I
have but only if it serves the greater
good it's easier for me to to just
blather on and maunder on endlessly
about myself but it doesn't serve the
greater good then we're just monitoring
on right so uh 80% of the chatting on
social media
the reason research was found was that
it just feels good so much so that
Harvard psychologists discovered that
individuals were willing to give up
money for the opportunity to disclose
information about
themselves huh say it again you're
willing to give up money just so you
have the opportunity to disclose more
information about yourselves
hey and there's there's also basically
people are willing to pay to talk about
themselves yes exactly and there's a
link to a study that Harvard did here
well I mean think about actually think
about social media yeah they're
gathering all that information on you
like people know when they use Facebook
like there they are their privacy is
being invaded but that's the price they
pay to be masturbatory yes I need to be
able to to you know have this digital
soapbox from which I can spell my
nonsense yeah and I think we're all
we're all culpable it's not to some
extent of course question then is like
how can we rein it in absolutely
unfortunately this propensity to
pontificate is at odds with our
collectively dwindling attention spans
which has been measured between as many
as 59 seconds to as few as eight seconds
so our attention span these days is
somewhere around eight seconds it makes
me sick man because I'm guilty of that
dude absolutely like it is it's yeah
this is a that it is a problem did you
see Tim Cook the other day Tim Cook
Apple guy yeah he I hear they're
announcing something about how we can
stop being distracted with our are
helpless bones yeah he was like going on
this he just basically was talking about
how he spends too much time on his phone
and um yeah I was just interesting to
see the CEO of Apple say hey you're I'm
on my phone too much that means that
there are a lot of other people who were
probably on their phone too much right
and like this guy who sells phones it's
funny cuz like I've never really had an
opinion about him but like what it's
kind of like you know oh
Patagonia when they're like you don't
need this jacket yeah it's like it's a
really it's it's a great marketing
because it seems honest I don't know if
he's being you know yeah if he's doing
it for the marketing or not well you you
can mark it honestly to right after the
whole advertising I said I wrote a few
months back was sort of about that like
there are ways to promote yourself
honestly to try to help other people and
that can actually help help you make
money along the way and some hopefully
my great hope here is because Apple
isn't Facebook or or Google where all of
the
attention or where attention is their
currency to a to a great extent with
Apple it's more about the the hardware
than it is the software right yeah and
so maybe they can they can manufacture
the hardware in a way I think you just
like accidentally like burned Apple it's
not so much about the software as much
as it's the hard way well no I mean they
recognize that that they're the money
they make is from selling hardware
Google doesn't make money from selling
hardware right and and Facebook doesn't
make money from selling hardware I think
both companies would like to just like
Apple would like to make money from
selling software but the software they
sell is essentially free right comes
with their hardware right and so when I
look at when I look at a company like
Apple maybe they can solve some problems
and they can make some money along the
way doing so in that problem with us
right now is do this eight second
attention span right yeah so let's see
it was a good give back a few say second
snakes is a barrage of information from
both verbal and digital sources the
ideal conversation should be total a
total give-and-take with each person
speaking about 50% of the time that
means staying quiet half of the time a a
tough but influential to outweigh that
means staying quiet half of the time a
tough but influential tool for business
all there's a link there to something
called a tool for business as Peter
Bergmann notes in the Harvard Business
Review silent silence is a great honor
silence is a greatly underestimated
source of power and silence we can hear
not only what is being said but also
what is not being said and silenced it
can be easier to reach the truth I think
ultimately I that there are some Zen
koans there about silence being the
ultimate truth or something like that
but sometimes we get really
uncomfortable and I get it with
especially if we're like on a podcast or
something you don't want I mean you can
pause for dramatic effect and there's
some radio hosts who do that really well
where you turn on the radio and you're
like is this just dead air and all of a
sudden you hear them talk right you were
you getting ready to change the channel
like they they've mastered that dramatic
pause but on a podcast sometimes I'm
just looking for the next thing
fill the fill to fill but the truth is
in our day-to-day conversations the
other other 167 hours a week that we
have we should practice a lot more
silence for listening right yeah
and so yes Alan's is definitely an
underestimated source of power to ensure
that you're giving your conversation
partner equal time and learning as much
as you can
Mark Golson a business psychiatrist says
it's important to pay attention to the
three stages of speaking to other people
and these are the tips I thought would
help with the the acquaintances /
friends / interest relationships in our
lives
number one the business stage on task
relevant and concise so so being
especially if you're wanting to interact
with someone stay on task be relevant
and be six I see it concisely the
succinct or concise the the the old
saying brevity is the soul of wit
mmm-hmm and there's true in writing when
we're communicating Seth Godin wrote
something recently about throat clearing
and how unnecessary it is some of them
are teaching in my my writing class for
years so how to write better a writing
class the one of the worst things about
blog posts is they could start two or
three paragraphs later there's all this
throat-clearing of I am really sorry
they have to sing and yeah I haven't
written in two weeks I'm really sorry
about that
and it's like no no no get to the point
but that's that's even more true and in
these conversations that that we're
having let me get to the point every
time I've seen a blog posts or a
newsletter or something come through and
it starts off with an apology like never
have I been like I'm so glad they said
I'm sorry I'm so glad they apologized
for X Y I mean it was speaking directly
towards what you said about oh I haven't
posted in a couple weeks I haven't
posted in a while they're in my inbox I
obviously want to read them yeah so you
know it's I don't need an apology but
yeah I totally agree and by the way I
probably because I have so many other
things going on I probably didn't notice
anyway if anything I'm glad you didn't
post and you took your time to write
something that was meaningful ray posted
just spamming me yeah thanks for not
just putting content out there yeah yeah
because that's offensive
right just being a con
generation machine no one wants that in
their inbox if that happens while you're
gonna unsubscribe right if you just keep
like getting spammed by someone you're
like oh this isn't adding value anyway
anyway
now here's Italy there are there a lot
of musicians I subscribed to in my inbox
and I like getting updates even if I
find out they're going on tour in
Indiana and Ohio and Michigan like it's
cool for me to see like a little update
from Andy Davis yeah and oh that's cool
he's doing something like that so I
don't mind something like that that's
not spammy your promo me it just it too
overly promo we it just tells me what's
going on in his sort of life torrent now
if you were to send me reminders every
day that he was going to Indianapolis
I'm like what are you doing right and so
there is that fine line you want to be
able to communicate without beating them
over the head and that goes back to this
first point stay on task relevant and
concise second point is the feel-good
stage so one so wonderful and
tension-relieving for you you don't even
notice the other person is not listening
so this is kind of a problem right where
you you or I or anyone we just start
like I have to get this information out
I'm this I'm this bottle of carbonated
information and as soon as I pop the top
it's just squirts everywhere yeah it's
that champagne celebration of it's an
explosion of information and and it
feels good to you
but it's bad because they don't even
notice the other person is not listening
I'm just bounding spouting about it have
you ever been talking to you all of a
sudden you notice like oh they're like
they've got the dead stare
oh dude as soon as someone's not
listening as soon as someone like breaks
eye contact with me mmm and I keep me in
the middle of a story they break eye
contact and they're looking at their
phone or you know they're looking off in
the distance they're looking at girl
walking by like I just stopped the story
and half the time they don't ask me to
finish maybe the other half of time to
be like oh could you finish that story
and I will finish it but 50% of the time
I'm like oh I've lost your attention and
this story is pointless isn't it it's
funny you say that I'm trying to think I
think it was Raymond Carver the short
story writer who
in order to find a good short story what
I'll do is I go talk to his friends like
he'll go to dinner with his friends or
lunch with his friends mmm and tell the
first half of the story yeah and then
he'll just trail off of something else
and that he knows the story's good if
people come back say hey back to that
one story you were telling though can
you finish that yeah he knows like yeah
I can finish okay lay yeah I can finish
that and then I can write this is
interesting not just with me but with
other people exactly so just be and then
so another tip from another writer David
Foster Wallace he would he would tell
his students that you are both you're
both simultaneously more interesting and
less interesting than you think and his
biggest challenge as a teacher was
trying to convince his students that
they were more interesting they had more
interesting stuff to write about and
they were also less interesting to your
trip to the grocery store to shop for
oranges probably isn't interesting but
there is something about that that might
be interesting the way that I would
reframe that is there's something about
that that might serve the greater good
there's some sort of lesson there yeah
you and I we were on tour 2014 we wrote
about a story about oranges about there
are bruises we bought this bag of
oranges in the backseat of your Corolla
yeah and the the Shawn put a link to
that in the show notes if you would
podcast Shawn it seems so long ago it
was four years ago but it seems like a
lifetime ago
yeah and it was called there will be
bruises but the the story wasn't about
shopping for oranges right right it was
about the the bruises that we were
taking on tour it was a metaphor yeah
exactly and so there's something
interesting there but it's probably not
the thing that you find to be
interesting right yeah and then the
third stage of the conversation he lists
here is the off track attempt to recover
stage the off track attempt to recover
stage rather than rien gauging by
listening the usual impulse is to talk
even more an effort to regain their
interest
and so see the aforementioned Harvard
results and so I think that's truly
where as I uh I know I I find especially
with people who I find to be way more
interesting in me than me like I think
back to we've done to podcast now with
Rob Bell and the thing that I wish would
have happened there is I would have I
would have heeded this advice which I
knew this advice but I wish I heated it
more I'd just shut up and listen more
and allow more talking ask the
appropriate questions that are that are
short enough that like just allow me to
get out of the way all right
instead of feeling the need to re-engage
by by talking and more instead of
listening right mm-hmm
goostin writes that he too was guilty of
this even after writing a book called
just listen that's when coach and NPR
radio host Marty Marty and NIM Marty NIM
co told him that he needed to start
practicing what he preaches holy moly I
should be NPR they're like hey practice
what you preach your you wrote a book
called just listen you know what you
need to just listen this is a great lake
example of how none of us are perfect
man right and like there is not the
there's not a perfect a
conversationalist there's not a perfect
minimalist you know I think this whole
journey for me I don't know about you
Josh but for me it's not about being
perfect it's not about having like the
perfect amount of stuff as much as
building really good habits in my life
and being able to talk about how I can
overcome these for the lack of a better
word these likes these these sins that I
am committing to like to have less and
less sense it makes me think about that
you know more wins and losses it's not
about just winning all the time as much
as it is about yeah being writing a book
about being a good conversationalist and
and you know someone calling you out on
it you can say yes like that's why I
wrote the book because I too struggle
with this and this is how I deal with it
exactly yeah
but for me my life is perfect because I
do have the right number of things right
what number is that they're they're
perfectly organized I can't tell you
them you have to buy my book
I'm gonna reveal it the ten steps to
have the perfect amount of things I want
to be you when I grow up yeah so let's
see nemco offered the following traffic
light strategy to rein in the chatter
you get a green light during the first
20 seconds your listener is liking you
as long as your statement is relevant to
the conversation and hopefully in
service of the other person so the first
20 seconds sort of the intro right you
get the green light and all of a sudden
it's like okay you have 20 seconds to be
really succinct you know they call this
an elevator pitch in some places right
so so what can I do to present the most
relevant thing sometimes I think that's
just asking a question because you can
do that in way less than 20 seconds and
it opens up the floor for the other
person allows you to listen and all of a
sudden you seem like a great
conversationalist yeah when you ask a
good quality question absolutely the
yellow light is the next 20 seconds now
the risk is increasing that the other
person is beginning to lose interest or
think you're long-winded so if you're
beyond 20 seconds there so okay unless
you're really compelling so go back
going back to the Rob Bell example you
and I saw him do a two-day event in
Laguna Beach mm-hmm he spoke for nine
hours a day for two days straight it was
incredible and I was like he but he also
knew when to take appropriate breaks
like two hours anybody all right let's
go take a break for tacos let's go take
a break for surfing and you're like wait
just finish the point and that was the
whole point like he kept you going there
it was like a 18 hour green light yeah
like God I wish it's it's hard for me to
talk for an hour for these podcasts let
alone nine hours by myself
yeah without notes have you or yeah
actually he made the notes as he went
late well it during the breaks he came
back like at napkin did you send like us
he's a he's a Mozart speaker man yeah he
definitely is and go back and listen to
both the podcast if you want to check
them out we did one in studio here with
him and he was the first guest on our
podcast episode 83 it's just called Rob
we did a live event with him
la and then of course you once you get
to the 42nd mark that's the red light
Ryan yes there's an occasional time you
want to run that red light and keep
talking but the vast majority of the
time you'd better stop or you're in
danger and so I just like to say this
right I can think of some people like
Rob or or others where I want to talk
far less like I just want to show up and
listen our friend Patrick roan who's
also been on the podcast was that
episode 8485 Shawn it'll be in the show
notes yeah will be in the show notes but
we did a live event with him in
Minneapolis but whenever I've had
conversation our documentary as well
whenever I have a conversation when we
go to a coffee shop I talk maybe 10
percent of the time and he sometimes
apologizes for being long-winded but I'm
just like no I I'm learning from you
yeah and he's got one of those voices
too man yeah he does just like he could
like just you know read me the newspaper
I would be like so interested by it the
phone book the phone
see yeah so I think that when you have
someone like like Rob or like like
patrick rome sometimes it just makes
sense to but you also have to recognize
the the setting as well so there are
times where it makes sense for me to
butt in but often with both of them I'm
butting in with questions like how can
you help me grow in a responsible way or
how are you using technology these days
and I find that when I do that when I
ask the appropriate questions I can
treat it as like the student teacher
there are other times though that I'm
going to be the teacher I need to make
sure it's appropriate I can't just go up
to someone on the street and say hey I'm
your teacher for today and here's my 60
seconds of pontification know that's a
crazy person yeah right and and so what
I what I need to do is make sure I have
the appropriate setting know when I can
go past the red light because someone
wants me to write it's a it's a
conversational emergency that's when you
go past the red light observing the time
it is observing the time isn't the only
strategy for engaging in healthy
communication goostin rights of the next
step is to determine why you talk so
much one reason may be that you're
trying to impress your conversation
partner so you're trying to be
impressive
right we do that through our things as
well obviously through our mementos
which we're going to talk about today
especially if you're aren't all that
confident on the inside some people
babble out of nerves attempting to
self-soothe while chattering still
others have never been taught the fine
of art of asking the right questions
that will draw the other person out and
then staying quiet while the while they
answer as Bergman says we all know how
to be silent the question is can we
withstand the pressure to speak I think
you were to translate that the
minimalist was like we all know how to
own fewer things but can we withstand
the pressure to to let go yeah and to
not bring in the superfluous things in
our lives and like you said it's
different for each of us yeah and it's
different for every conversation what is
superfluous in this conversation I mean
it's like when I quickly got off the
basketball talk there but we can go back
to basketball talk to talk about for
half an hour this just isn't the
appropriate time for that right and so
it's easy to take a quick off-ramp and
notice that I okay what's the quick
off-ramp here and then moving on to
whatever the next thing is so we'll put
a link to that company article yeah I
think it was just really good follow-up
for for last week and one one other
thing that I forgot to mention or really
didn't didn't drive home last week is
frequency doesn't equal friendship so
there is a minimal maxim for yeah just
because you hang out with someone
everyday doesn't mean it's the best
friendship in the world yeah I can take
the easy example coworkers of course you
spend a lot of time with them every day
because you have to write if you're if
you're working at the cubicle next to
someone you're probably gonna spend a
lot of time with and hopefully you can
build a good acquaintance ship with them
and and you're good acquaintances you
get along really well and you have a
nice working dynamic but just because
you're around someone doesn't that
doesn't mean they're your friend and the
opposite is also true I think some of my
closest relationships some of my closest
primary and secondary relationships are
people I see once or twice a year and I
mean even people like my brother who
I've been really reconnecting with
within the last year we took different
paths after turning 18 and and well he's
a year older than me so he was 19 and
it's like whoever had some huge
falling-out or some
we just drifted in different directions
and continued the drift and drifted a
little bit close from time to time but
now there were a certain stage in our
life or both in our late 30s we've been
able to sort of reflect back and we're
communicating a lot more and and so
sometimes that distance creates the path
for you to reconnect in a way but other
times there are friends like my friend
Adam in in Tennessee who I see him once
or twice a year if I'm lucky we might
have a conversation once a month or once
every other month and there are some of
the most meaningful conversations I have
and part of that is because of the
distance if we were to chat every single
day it made we they may not have the
conversation may not have the same
weight but we can go away and sort of
like we basically he and I do a podcast
once a month without recording it is the
way that I like I'm like this would be
if we were recording this would be the
best podcast ever yeah and the part of
me like that makes it even more precious
because it's not being recorded for
posterity it's just sort of out there in
the ether and it's gone and it makes
this this beautiful ephemeral experience
and we can do that once a month to come
back and so one of the things I want to
just drive home is you can have great
relationships with someone who's on the
other side of the country other side of
the world Derek Siver's talked about
this his five closest friends three of
them he has never met in person but he
stalks them on the phone all the time
yeah and so think about that as well you
can have unconventional relationships
and still have them be rather meaningful
absolutely you ready for these
voicemails let's do it here's our first
question from Ryan we got a question
from Georgia in Montreal or was it
Montreal in Georgia I had her at the
first time that was after listening to
the nostalgia episode I took a long hard
look at the hoard of baby clothes and
other baby
like baby items that no longer fit or
add value to my son's life but that I
was holding on to for a possible future
child this process forced me to really
set my intentions and priorities for the
next few years and it shifted my
perspective in many ways to be honest
though I do sometimes have feelings of
loss or other difficult emotions when
having some big decisions
and whenever I let go things even though
it can feel good I sometimes feel this
loss so how do you deal with the or
tolerate the emotional journey that
minimalism can pick you on even when
there's joy with let's say for example
keeping just a few select items that
trigger the happy feelings how do you
deal with the ambivalent feelings when
letting goes other stuff alright so the
word ambivalent here I would use a
different word so I'm ambivalent about
ambivalence right if you're ambivalent
torn item I tend to let it go because if
it's if I'm ambivalent it's like why do
I want to hold on to this thing right
yeah just to be clear ambivalence for me
it means like basically having not
feeling not a feeling one way or the
other a feeling that's not one way or
the other it is in between you know
either pain or pleasure it's it's
nothing so much I think maybe what
George is saying is ambivalence are
worse like if you feel ambivalence or
you feel negative feeling which clearly
she does with some of these she has
these hoards of baby clothes and other
baby items mhm that she's talking about
and she's holding on to them just in
case she has another kid in the future
right she's not really sure it's not
like she's pregnant right now and she
knows there's another kid at least said
that wasn't clear from from her message
so so she also mentioned that triggers
and she has these these holding on to
some items that trigger these positive
memories and I just wanna say yes
congratulations because the memories
aren't in the things the memories are
are in us and sometimes though those
things can trigger the memories that are
inside us so by holding on to a few
items having fewer things we can
actually use those to trigger those good
feelings in us
however by watering it down with tens of
thousands of old baby items just sitting
around in boxes and bins those aren't
really triggers for old memories those
are just weights that are holding you
back yeah it sounds like which they were
just in case items for her yeah rather
than just for when right so no I mean so
that to me that is you know earlier when
I talked about how this podcast could be
called boundaries like for someone like
Georgia she has to be able to create
these boundaries like it so when it
comes to just in case of course we have
the 20 20 just in case for oh we've got
the 90 90 rule there
different rules that you and I have set
up for ourselves yes to help us not hold
on to these things so with Georgia I
mean the first thing I thought of was
well she does not you know she's not
sure she's gonna have a kid or not so
what are the rules that she has for
herself in keeping these baby clothes
yeah so you know having the rule of just
throwing them out or just donating them
I should say um you know that's I guess
that's okay that doesn't seem like it
doesn't seem very deliberate to me if
she's still wonder you know questioning
whether or not she's gonna have a kid in
the next year so yeah and then holding
on to everything just in case that also
doesn't seem like the best solution
there's something in the middle there
and really like Georgia's gonna have to
figure out what that middle is for her
yeah and so asking yourself what is your
outcome here because if you do plan to
have another kid then the question is
win yes so if you're saying I'm gonna
have a kid in two years okay great then
then the next question is what are the
items that you want to hold on to for
that kid because clearly you don't want
to hold on to all of these things most
likely you've learned some lessons from
the first kid you always do right now
I've learned a whole lot of lessons from
having Ellis you just turned five
recently we took her down to Disneyland
posted that crazy picture of her on the
on the so good on stories Oh Mike
it was just good I had to redownload
Instagram to post it and it was just
this you know zoom in zoom in you can
actually find on my Instagram stories
right now put it on just still on there
well they you know what are those things
called did I don't yeah the at the top
the the Instagram stories tabs you have
these different tabs the moments moments
they're called oh so it's like Center
them yeah it's under the family and not
even know that existed yeah it's under
the family moment on my my Instagram
stories I'm just at Joshua fields
Melbourne if you want to see the most so
good it's the best family picture we've
ever taken and it is pure it's remember
a Leoville Balsas term joy fear yeah
that is she personified the expression
of joy fear especially when you zoom in
our face
it was the precipice of total terror and
also utter and complete joy it's the
same moment when I saw that picture when
we came off the ride I was like oh my
god like Ella's she's never gonna trust
us again uh-huh but like because she
looks so scared right but dude she was
like we ride that again
yeah yeah go do that what again
sweetheart that line is two hours long I
don't care let's riding together yeah
she loved him like the what's gonna
splash mountains a log flume ride and
yeah it was just scary enough that she
loved it anyway I've learned a whole lot
of lessons through my five years with
her Wow when I met Dex Ella was was one
so three and a half years with her and
I've learned a lot of lessons so if we
ever had another kid in the future which
we likely won't but if we had a second
kid there were certainly things I
learned from that from this crash test
dummy named Ella that we we all carry
forward right no I and that the truth is
like I learned really Ella wasn't the
crash test dummy I was I was the crash
test dummy for parenting right like I'm
learning I'm learning how to become a
better parents one of the hardest things
I've ever done it's probably the hardest
thing I've ever done and especially for
me with with my personality and so I've
learned a lot and I know that Kerry if I
had a second kid carry that forward
there are some things literal things
physical things I'd get rid of and also
at different experiences I bring in more
of and bring in less and so what are the
things you're gonna want to and then of
course if two years from now you're like
okay I've decided I'm not going to get
pregnant then you give yourself full
permission there's a drop-dead date on
on these items there's an expiration
date for these items right and you want
to give yourself permission to let go
though so maybe that said having the
9090 rule it's the one-year rule and if
you're not pregnant in a year then you
decide you know I'm not getting value
from these things anymore someone else
could get value from them so I better
let them go so someone else can and that
Ryan goes back to your point
differentiating the just in case items
which don't hold on to them if they're
just in case hold on to them if they're
just for win and you can honestly say
you know when you're going to use them
right now George is somewhere right in
between and so you need to set up a rule
for yourself that says at this point
they're no longer just for one item this
is when they become just in case and
when it said just in case item I'm
getting it the hell out of here
yeah well it's funny because like when
it comes to just in case items there's
always going to be a reason to hold on
it I mean hoarders like the true sense
of the word quarter you walk into
someone's home you can't see their floor
got a newspaper sect everywhere they are
holding on to those newspapers just in
case yes
now most people they're not gonna have
sex in newspapers they're gonna let them
go for one reason to the other I would
encourage you know people to look at
that reason and see if they can apply to
other areas of their life what a great
point and see if it makes sense but you
know listening to George George's
question I two things came to mind and
I'm not trying to make this black or
white but I feel like one or two things
are happening here with Georgia either a
she is holding on to stuff just in case
or maybe when she maybe she got she let
it go I couldn't really tell by the
question that she let it go or was how I
okay so let's let's say she does let it
go and she experiences regret a year
from now and she's like oh man like I
really really should not have let that
stuff go and here are the reasons why
then that's okay like it's again there
is no perfect minimal list you might get
rid of something that you wish you would
have hung on to but learn from that
lesson
don't don't continue to you know just
throw everything away to only experience
that same regret every single time III
can't I wish I had a sexy answer when
people are like hey guys what's one
thing you got rid of that you really
feel a lot of regret with and like I
don't have a sexy answer for that and at
but I'm sure there are people out there
who have went down this road and they do
feel regret of getting rid of something
like really look at that regret and ask
like how could have I avoided that and
here's why I needed to avoid that the
other the other thing that I think might
be going on is Georgia might just have
you know these tents you might have had
these tendencies to hold on to stuff
from the beginning of life I mean IIIi
have had mentoring students who they're
like you know I got rid of this one
thing and its really really driving me
crazy I don't know why it's driving me
crazy but it's really weighs on me and
when I think about it you know I'm a
little upset that I let it go and in a
lot of the times I'll take you know kind
of deep into that and when I find out is
that these are feelings that they've had
ever since they were a kid they were you
know collected rocks I collected sticks
that you know then they got rather stick
pile and they've felt bad about letting
it go my point is is that there are
these emotions that some
that we are born with sometimes that
emotionally makes sense because we feel
them right but logically they don't make
sense yeah and and I think that that is
a very important thing to to recognize
essentially like I think about my my my
I'm very prone to getting angry really
easily uh-huh and I used to think that I
was justified and get especially my
relationship soon as I get offended as
soon as I get jealous as soon as I get
insecure and then I would you know I get
angry and I would voice my my angry
feeling and I felt completely justified
in doing that well once I realized that
that me acting on that is actually
ruining relationships I had to really
question whether or not those emotions
whether they logically made sense for me
to have now you could be right or you
can be in love you can't be both right
exactly man so so you know what when I
look at like me getting angry really
easily I know that when I have this
anger this feeling of you know anger
shoot through me I've got to be able to
look at that and say okay Ryan I know
you feel this way yeah but but really
like how would how would the best
version of yourself react in this
situation so I have tools to help calm
me down whether it's you know taking a
deep breath or a couple deep breaths or
whether it's like rephrasing the way
something was a position to me whatever
it might be I have different tools to
help me deal with this emotion what I'm
getting at is is that it's important for
me to recognize that this emotion that I
have is not valid it is not adding any
value it is you know by and large it's
not adding any value so I'm just trying
to relate here with Georgia where she's
got to be able to look at this feeling
that that this hoarding feeling that she
has and she's got to look at that and
say is this valid if it isn't then she
has to find ways to kind of tell that
that that hoarding mentality or that you
know just in case mentality to to kind
of sit on the back burner yes I
understand that I feel that way but
logically I'm not gonna sit here and you
know have a storage storage locker full
of baby clothes I have to find the
in-between and she might get rid of the
baby clothes and she still might feel a
little bit
of a loss she so might feel a little bit
of regret but to me what really is
important is whether or not that regret
is valid or not yes yeah well and so so
you're bringing up a couple things that
I want to talk about one is I don't
think the the fear of potential regret
so that if you the fear of potential
regret is not a good reason to not let
go absolutely and because one you don't
know whether or not if that's the only
reason you're holding on to something is
because you might regret it in some
hypothetical future then it's probably
not adding value to your life and it's
not going to and is likely not going to
add value to your life right now you're
also talking about emotions and feelings
and I've always equated those two as
being synonymous but I went to a Sam
Harris event recently man well he was
there with an author Antonio D'Agostino
I believe anyway I'm messing with the
name he has a new book out that
delineates the the the the difference
between emotion and feeling a feeling is
something that we experience internally
an emotion is something that we react on
either either consciously or
unconsciously an emotion the the feeling
could be fear the emotion is that we the
heart the the heart starts beating
quickly and we start getting the sweaty
palms that interesting and so there is
this differentiation between the two and
so what she might be feeling it are
these emotions because it's making her
feel a particular way the the the sense
of urgency of I can't let go because I'm
gonna need this so I'm gonna hold on
because otherwise like I feel this like
anxious feel emotion anxiety can be an
emotion and the feeling is like you said
it may or may not be justified right
there isn't a real fear here of letting
go because the worst thing that can
happen if you let go of these baby
clothes the worst thing that can happen
is someone else is going to get some
value from them and you might have to
buy some used baby clothes in the future
alright man Georgia I'd love to see your
copy of our book it's called essential
and we wrote a hundred and fifty essays
about intentional living so it's twelve
different areas of intentional living
that we identified and one of them has
to do with stuff so the things that we
bring into our lives so podcast Jean if
you could reach out to Georgia and send
her an audio book copy of essential it's
called essential essays by the
minimalists and if you like this podcast
you'll definitely like the audio book
version of essential or if she wants the
book book version or the eBook version
please reach out to her and send her
that Georgia thanks to your question our
next question is from Suzanne and Munich
Germany I'm not fighting a lot and I
write a gratitude journal every day I
tried to do it on my computer but it
doesn't feel natural I want to be
disconnected when I do so now I have a
big collection of journals from the past
years and simply cannot get rid of them
I thought about scanning them but it
doesn't feel right to read them on my
computer and I do read them from time to
time and feel amazing about all the
credit you'd do you have any advice so
do we have any advice I mean here's some
things that probably told Georgia on on
the last voicemail but I think these
apply just as much to to Suzanne so she
said she's tried to write on the
computer but it doesn't feel natural
mm-hmm
nothing feels natural first was the
first time you've done it right first
time I played basketball it didn't feel
natural to me right and I think that's
true the first time I wrote a sentence
it didn't feel natural to me first time
I tried to write a book it sure as hell
didn't feel natural to me the first time
I wrote a blog post it didn't feel
natural to me what feels natural is
something we've done for a long time
that all of a sudden seems natural to us
but it took a long time to build up that
skill it doesn't mean you don't have the
talent for it it means you you took time
to to gratitude journal every single day
so something I would recommend and this
could apply it to Georgia as well but
for Suzanne I I think that that you
probably want to write about the
experience and the emotions you're
feeling of letting go and one of the
things you can do is start a blog and
and maybe you can keep it a private blog
even if you want and unless you want to
make a public which i think is great you
can learn out loud as we say and
actually Sean can you put a link we
someone who asked us how we started our
blog we have a blog post called how to
start a successful blog now you can to
redefine success in a bunch of different
ways it doesn't mean having millions of
readers it can mean that you're doing it
every day or that you're learning a lot
in public and so the first thing I'll
recommend yeah is is write in public if
you can write and then some other
practical tips why not take pictures or
scan those journals or and yeah they
said wow I don't know if I'm about doing
all of them why don't you just do one
and keep the journal see how it feels
and then anytime you need to go back and
reference that one journal go back and
reference it online first and by the way
some of the ones that you scan you can
make them searchable so you don't have
to flip through a hundred different
pages to find what you want so and if
you don't wanna scan it yourself you
don't rip out the pages there are places
that you can skin will scan you can send
your your your journals or whatever off
they'll scan it for you and either send
it back to you or you can have them
dispose of it as well let's put a link
to at least one of the scanning places
that we've we've had recommended to us
recently so Sean if you could do that
and then on top of that when it comes to
the the physical things getting back to
Georgia is maybe take a picture of some
of the things you're letting go of if
you're still trying to hold onto those
triggers of memories you know I don't
want to lose the I know the memories are
the things but I want to hold onto these
triggers even though the journals yeah
then you could take a picture of it and
I think you can let go yeah some
questions that I would ask Susan Ryan
you something what you think about these
why are you asking this question yeah
and and for me it's it's it sounds to me
like maybe you want to get rid of these
journals or maybe you want to know what
you should want does that make sense
it does I think so I I guess let me let
me rephrase it maybe she thinks like I
should want to get rid of these journals
right like I was just thinking that
sometimes someone who's like okay you
know what I'm going to be a minimalist
I'm gonna apply this this velocity of my
philosophy to my life
and Josh and Ryan they don't have a lot
of journals right so I shouldn't have a
lot of journals right so I should want
to get rid of these but I really don't
want to yeah is that kind of worries
absolutely mate maybe she actually does
want to hear and maybe there are burden
to her yeah but if they're not a burden
to you then here's your permission to
hold on to them pleases you you don't
have to feel compelled to get rid of
everything to be a minimalist in fact I
think about our friend Drew who did the
music for our documentary minimalism he
has this he's booking ready to do the
kickstarter project for this really nice
handcrafted journal that has like a
refillable liner in it and it's gorgeous
he showed me like a preliminary video -
it is beautiful
and he's like I'd like to have one
journal on my desk and he I here's my
sketches and everything so I want it to
be one really high quality beautiful
item but also I can replace and remove
the inserts and put them on my shelf so
I can go back and reference them because
I use this all the time for my work I'm
like that sounds awesome and you a you
don't to justify it to me but it sounds
to me like that would make sense and if
I needed to work in that same way that I
would want the same thing a beautiful
object that I found value in and it
sounds like Suzanne finds value and the
more value in the act of journaling than
she does in the object itself the object
is just a vehicle that provides the
value and so maybe a blog could be just
as good of an answer and it could allow
her to expose her gratitude in public
and maybe just maybe that'll help other
people as well yeah absolutely you know
the question that that I would ask Susan
Suzanne here is are these causing more
pain than pleasure yeah is it a net
positive or negative that's I mean that
is that's only for Susanna no for me
it'd be a net negative because I don't
want to have a bookshelf full of
journalists that's my preference and
preferences or what make the world go
around that's right
so if Susan's preference if she if she
prefers to have a bookshelf full of her
journals then then you know that's great
I mean she's obviously asking this
question because she feels a little bit
of a little bit of pain so again she's
got to look at it and say is am i
experiencing more pain
then I am pleasure here like I thought
about when I was answering her question
I thought man my car it causes me a lot
of pain like I gotta like it the oil
changed it's it's it's an older car like
you know leaks when it rains mm-hmm
that's why we moved to Los Angeles just
so your card stops exactly although for
some reason I had this rough spot that
is like I gotta get something again
gotta do something about this rough spot
moving to LA next to the ocean like it
is this rust is like spreading pretty
quickly now oh wow so there's all this
pain associated with my car but well hey
I'm not gonna get rid of it because la
is a driving city unfortunately I'm not
going to go into debt to get another car
right but ultimately you know there are
these reasons I have to keep my car even
though it cause causes me pain it is a
net positive for me to have in my life
yeah so so that's really I think where
Susan needs to look you know the other
thing too is are the rules that she can
set up for herself with these journals
are there boundaries that she can set up
that maybe it's somewhere in the middle
of scanning and getting rid of every
single physical journal yeah and then
not doing anything right you know where
is the middle ground she could let's see
I've got some stuff written down here um
so if it was me I'd look at okay because
she said she just go back to me she
reads them which is great like I've
never went back and read any of my
journal stuff but and the only thing
I'll push back on on Suzanne about here
is do you actually do that or is it an
aspirational thing right sometimes we we
get books or whatever we have journals
because we aspire to do something I
aspire to go back and look at that
but do I actually do it yes so she said
you know and I sometimes go back to read
the journals does that really mean and
one day I know I'm gonna want to go back
and read these journals you're
absolutely right and do you get value
from the next question right yeah
actually get value from going back or do
you do it out of a sense of obligation
so so you know let's say that she is
actively reading some of these entries
let's make that assumption that's what
she said in the voicemail so let's just
make that assumption that she is going
back and she's experiencing some of
these gratitude
a journal entries that she's written in
the past I would say again like which
ones hasn't she read in a while or
haven't read it all like you could start
there that's a boundary I'm gonna get
rid of all the journals I haven't even
looked at or what which ones does she
keep going back to like could she make
like you know a best-of yeah hey best of
gratitude moments and maybe blog about
that in public again
can you imagine right if you and I just
did our blog in private like in a
journal yeah like how much how much we
would have wasted not helping other
people like our attention our time our
talent our skills if we would have just
done like we would has come we will come
in this room at once a week and just
have this conversation and not publish
the podcast there would be a bunch of
people who weren't getting value from
now again you you have to realize now
everything you write is interesting but
what are the interesting parts from
those journals maybe the but best of is
such a great way to convey that to the
world in the world will give value out
of them yeah dude I was thinking she
could like she could create a boundary
like okay here the top 50 things that
I'm grateful for yeah anytime I I'm
having a bad day I'm feeling upset I can
go to this list of 50 things and remind
myself why I am so grateful and maybe
you know some things will fall off and
other things would add it to that list
but I'm just encouraging Suzanne here to
again create some boundaries around
these journals a you know or I guess
like the first question I would ask
myself if I was Suzanne is what am I
getting out of keeping these journals
and then what am I gonna get out of it
if I get rid of these journals she's got
to ask yourself questions like that to
figure out what her what her exact
preferences and what's gonna make her
feel best about about these journals
there's not one right way to do it I
wish I could be like you know what Oh
Suzanne thank you for that journal
question Josh and I just wrote an essay
on this the perfect amount of journals
they have is 10 journals okay that's way
too many for me right right and it may
not be enough for her and so the
question then is what is enough and I
think row that's what minimalism is it's
the art of having an
yeah Susie and I'd love to send you a
copy of the the German version of
minimalism with meaningful life it just
came out in Germany and it's it I
believe it's in German I wasn't able to
read all the words in it but it
certainly looked German to me it's my
favorite cover that we've ever had I'm
looking I'm looking forward to seeing
the physical version hasn't shown up
here at the studio yet but it's in
Germany now so yeah minimalism with a
meaningful life in Germany as soon as we
get a physical copy of that in Shawn if
you could send it to her
or if she wants the audiobook it's not
in German but if she wants that we
happen to send her an audio book version
of minimalism live a meaningful life all
right
Oh we'd love to hear what you have to
say so if you have a comment or a tip
about mementos or boundaries including
Vice for any of our callers today leave
us a voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo right from your phone
to podcast at the minimalists comm where
our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode and stay tuned to the end
of this episode for some of our favorite
comments and tips from last week in
previous week's Ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it is time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media I wish I had
the dimmer switch near me I would like
put it up and down for the video guys
create some Lightning effect podcast
Shawn can do something you can add some
lightning in later I'm asked enough of
him already
but we're hiring a filmmaker soon we'll
talk about that a little bit anyway
we're on Twitter and Facebook and
Instagram at the minimalists is our
handle on all three of those platforms
during the lightning round Ryan and I
each do our best to answer every
question which is a short shareable
lesson 140 character response we also
put the text of these minimal Maxim's in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our pithy answer is on social media if
you'd like and now you can find all of
our quotes in one place
minimal maxims comm thank you very much
to Jessica Lowe Lynn Williams she is our
social media manager and a talented
person she is loving and doing a great
job with the constraints of our new
social media strategy yeah for those who
don't know about it we did a whole
podcast episode it was like 118 or 119
called social media talking about how
the minimalists are using social media
in 2018 where we're using a lot
differently we're trying to use it to
educate and inform and also propagate
our art as
as opposed to generate more content and
so you can find us on all those
platforms and also our quotes over at
minimal Maxim's com
all right our first lightning round
question is from Amy I'm not attached to
the gobs of knickknacks and heirlooms I
inherited but what should I save that my
children might appreciate all of it Amy
my big storage unit buy a bigger one
right so so the stat that is always
staggering to me there are five times
the storage units as a number of
Starbucks in this country and there are
a lot of Starbucks and so and by the way
our houses are twice as large as they
were 5060 years ago and our garages are
overflowing with stuff so much so that
we can't fit our cars in our garages and
still we have the need for these storage
lockers I like think so the United
States I'm guessing from that stat has
by far the most storage out of any other
country in the world I would think so I
mean maybe there's places like Dubai or
something but yeah but it I'm just
thinking like what how does that make us
better or how does that make us happier
in fact maybe great if it did the data
would show that it makes us depressed
right I mean we are I don't know how old
this stat is but I know you know five
six years ago the most depressed country
in the world was the United States and
it's also one of the richest countries
in the world yeah and there's something
oh what's I can't think of the term
where you got you know two graphs that
are compared there's something like
there's there's something that is
signifying an inverse relationship yes
thank you yes there is an inverse
relationship I think between between
debt mmm-hmm
the things we have storage I don't know
I'm just that that's just my two cents
ma'am I want I could be way out but I
agree with you and so before I get to my
really short answer here maybe the thing
is when you think about it just
practically like when's the last time
you got excited about a storage unit
dude this every any storage unit I've
ever had in my life has been a burden
yes
absolutely that's a good that's a
minimal maximum there Sean it's
attributed to both of us so my short
answer is too few is greater than too
much what I mean by that is sometimes we
have to deprive ourselves temporarily to
figure out what actually adds value to
our lives get rid of the access stuff
makes room for for what well for
experience but also for the things that
we're truly going to find value in and
by the way I think your kids future self
will likely appreciate if you let go so
they don't have to yeah you remember
that the event we had and like the the
couple was like man our parents getting
ready to pass away and we got all this
stuff to deal with and like it was
stressing them out so bad yeah and then
like the next people who had a comment
to say they were like you know like
right now we were holding on to all this
stuff for our kids and we're here to get
the leverage to like let go and like
seeing those two people stressing over
their parents stuff it was like a great
signifier for them on probably what
they're doing to their kids by holding
on to all that stuff yeah yeah yeah my
short answer would be when it comes to
saving precious heirlooms avoid the
guessing game by asking your kids what
they want now if your kids are one in
two years old and they can't answer it
well you can do one or two things like
you can just hold on everything and wait
until you know they will give you an
answer or you could just kind of start
paring down on this stuff right now I'm
not encouraging Amy here to just throw
away everything yeah but certainly she
could ask herself well if I was a kid if
or what if I if I was 15 what I want to
be burdened by all this stuff mmm yeah
yeah and by the way when they turn 18
it's all their stuff they have to take
it with them yeah it becomes their stuff
and all of a sudden you realize really
quickly what stuff they want to hold on
to because it all becomes just in case
at that point absolutely all right
what's next question our next question
is from Angela my dad passed away very
suddenly this past month Angela I am
really sorry to hear about your loss he
didn't have much but there are so many
of his objects of his that hold memories
for me
part of me doesn't want the clutter but
I miss him and these objects remind me
of him
it feels painful to think of donating
them or tossing them before we give our
answers do like I just want to say to
Angela like we are not trying to make
your loss easy like it and to make it
sound easy to just get rid of stuff know
what we're doing to make your life
easier going forward absolutely
yeah my short answer for you Angela is
if you wait until you're completely
ready you may never let go I think
that's that's sort of the the I mean I
think of this David Foster Wallace quote
about it's from Anthony Jess he said
everything I've ever let go of has claw
marks on it hmm it's because letting go
is a hard exercise it's not I mean now
it's easier for me to do because I've
built up that letting go muscle but it's
even for me it's still not easy right
and then the easiest thing in the world
to just let go of something and and so I
I think about this is like you're never
gonna be a hundred percent ready to let
go but when you're above 50 percent
ready to let go
yeah which she is right now she's asking
these questions which means you're
pretty close to that already
yeah then one of the what is the
leverage you you need to let go all so
here's another pithy thing for you that
it's a question worth asking what's the
cost of not letting go
mmm and I don't mean there's a physical
cost if you have to rent a storage
locker or have a separate room or
whatever to store all these things in
what's the emotional cost of carrying
this baggage literal baggage the
figurative baggage of all these things
that aren't adding value what are they
getting in the way of what have been not
allowing you to make a room for in terms
of space but also time and attention and
in that space that occupies in the back
of your mind you're always thinking
about these things maybe it's not giving
you the room that you need to make new
memories new meaningful experiences yeah
and of course our memories aren't in our
things our memories are in us and so
those are some some basic tips to at
least think about Angela I'm really
sorry about your loss yeah you know I
the lesson that you have shared with
with me and with our audience a lot
about how having fewer sentimental items
increases the value
of those sentimental items that you hold
on to yeah you get more value from them
and you know if I was to look at you
know the I guess like the the terminus
of of Angela holding on to everything
she would be sitting in a room
surrounded by all these things from her
father yeah and she wants to honor her
father I want her to honor her father I
want her to honor the memories sitting
in a room steeped with memories of
losing your father I don't know in the
end I'm not a psychiatrist I'm not a
doctor there's just my two cents but I
don't know if that's the healthiest way
to deal with a loss because you're all
not the way he would want you to deal
with it either
probably not so you know think about
that - Angela having you know thousands
and thousands of of these sentimental
items is is it going to truly like is it
going to help you to to mourn and to to
let you know to let your your father go
in a way of accepting his passing or is
it going to make that process more
difficult now if her answer is
unequivocally thing it's gonna help me
deal with this this this product it's
gonna help me with this process I'm
gonna feel better about it this is gonna
be best for me then do that Angela but
yeah I think if that's your answer
you're probably lying to yourself yeah
or or it's yeah there's um there's
there's because I don't want to say
turns just say like her emotions is her
lying to herself but but I I mean I
guess going back to what we were talking
about at the beginning of this podcast
and those first questions is that
feeling of holding on to everything does
that logically make sense like yours is
your you know yourself for five years
from now are they are logically are they
gonna look at it and say or you know as
Angelus self gonna look at herself and
say oh you know what I'm so glad that
you held on to every single memento and
you hold on to every single keepsake
know her future self isn't gonna want to
deal with all that stuff and so the time
to deal with it is is now or at least a
start dealing with because the feeling
that she's experienced now as a feeling
of being burdened
and of course your father doesn't want
you to feel burdened now you may have
had a difference opinion about some of
the stuff for the trinkets or whatever
but now that he's gone the one thing you
know is he didn't want you to feel
burdened by by losing him right and so
you asked himself some of that will add
value to your life and you have to
figure out what that is maybe set those
aside and then start to figure out a
plan of dealing with with the rest of it
alright my short answer is create
boundaries or you'll hold on to
everything and you know I was thinking
about well I usually suggest like
mentoring students if they've got this
hoard of stuff and they know they got to
get rid of some of it you know I always
think like start small you know you know
to get a little bit of momentum built
and my it might be a little bit bit bit
painful getting rid of some of those
stuff at first but then that's saying
came into my head of no pain no gain
right and you know I don't want to tell
this to Angela right now
you know just experiencing this this
very recent loss I'm not gonna be like
Angela get rid of it no pain no gain but
what I will say is that more gain more
pain yeah that's my favorite minimal
maximum of the show and I completely
agree with a as we as we keep gaining
more stuff we start to feel we start to
feel the pain now the pain can present
itself in many ways anxiety with
insecurity with worry yes absolutely are
we got one more question here this one
is from casket kicker I'm not sure what
that means right cassock is kicker asks
what are your thoughts on keeping
mementos from old romantic relationships
god I love this question and I can't
wait to talk to you about a good one if
you'd like to hear our answer to this
question you can listen to this week's
PostScript episode over at the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively to our patreon supporters
that's why it's a private podcast it's
just for those folks so if you want to
support our show and help keep this
podcast a hundred percent advertisement
free then head on over to the
minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes the minimalist private podcast
feed includes our monthly ask
minimalist anything episodes unreleased
recordings of our live events and the
entire back catalogue of past private
episodes once you become a supporter
you'll also receive a personal link to
our private podcast feed so that it
plays in whatever podcast app you use
right next to the podcast you're
listening to right now so basically it
shows up as your listen to the
minimalist podcast then you have the
minimalist private podcast as a separate
fee but it shows up right there in that
same podcast app like Apple podcasts or
feedly or overcast whatever you listen
to and as a patreon supporter you also
receive access to our monthly livestream
videos as well as first access to
tickets to all of our live events before
those tickets are available to the
general public find all the details and
all the good stuff over at the
minimalists comm slash support and here
is a snippet from this week's PostScript
episode Kassie kicker says what are your
thoughts on keeping mementos from old
romantic relationships man this might be
our shortest PostScript ever yeah don't
do it yeah thanks have a good one yeah I
think that's about it I mean oh well
let's talk about why well let's talk
about less what why is it a no for us
and that's define was define what
romantic relationships mean
[Music]
all right and we're back if you want to
hear that full conversation you can
become a patron over at the minimalists
comm okay now it's time for our added
value portion of the show this is where
we need to talk about something has
added value to our lives recently let me
guess you have a list of three things no
I have one thing today it's funny guys
like the last few episodes you've had
three try I had this like cascade of
like 40 things I've been trying to pare
it down so I'm like I'll just take three
this week this week oh I thought I only
I'm down there like two or three I
thought three was um it was like very
soothing for your OCD added value
doesn't work for things no the UH for me
man I am gonna recommend um there's a
there's a gal named Adrienne and she's
got a yoga channel on YouTube so I think
it's just called yoga with Adriene
uh-huh Moriah does this every single
morning she's been doing this every
single morning when we're on the road
dude she can keep up her habits better
than I can
yeah like when we're on the road I will
be in the smallest ass hotel room and
show us be like hey there's this one
little spot for yoga I'm gonna take over
the spot can you just like not be in my
area for a little bit and I totally
support her cuz it's a really healthy
habit and she looks really hot when
she's doing yoga but anyway she does she
does this yoga practice every single
morning with Adriene the reason why I
like Adrienne is AI like I have done a
few of these and they're great but what
I like about Adrienne is that she she
has yoga routines that can go from like
10 minutes to an hour oh nice so it's
like you can kind of pick and choose how
much time you have to do these practices
she's she's like funny and it's not like
this you know I'm gonna take myself very
seriously and these yoga poses I mean
she has fun while she's doing it let's
go um it's not very woooe so it's like
it's very practical and it's just it's
very simple it's very very simple I've
never seen such a simple like yoga video
and she's always got like her dog every
once in a while that light comes in and
like you know takes away or actually
doesn't take away it kind of distracts
but it's a good distraction
you know it's kind of cute and funny
when her dog comes in every once in a
while but but yeah that'll be linked to
in the show notes if you are someone who
is like you know what I'd really want to
like start practicing yoga I would
highly recommend looking at her videos
I like the ten minute thing sounds a
good game yeah you could pick a 10
minute video and just go for 10 minutes
and see how you like it and maybe do
that video like Mariah she sometimes
will do the same video every week or
every day during the week sometimes just
switch it up every day but there's so
much there and it's all free and yeah
you're gonna love it
Ryan have you listened to the Snow
Patrol's new album I have neither Snow
Patrol right I do I think ours was like
they're big yeah I've never like I've
never I loved their first album but this
one is so today they have the first
album in seven years so the lead singer
Gary Lightbody he had a really bad like
depression and alcoholism so 7 years
between albums because he was dealing
with that Oh about two years ago he
became sober and really it was like
battling his demons so this new album it
is like it's so hopeful I did the the
first thing I think was called don't
give in and it's it's just about that
you can tell like and there's this pain
in his voice that is like post
problem-solving pain but also still
amongst the problem like you realize
once you solve the problem you have to
continue to solve the problem a it's
like when Michael Jordan won the
championship he was focused on the next
championship they all opposites also
true and we get past one sort of hurdle
it doesn't mean there aren't going to be
future hurdles you're actually going to
keep seeing that same hurdle over and
over and this album is about that it's
called wildness let's go check it out
man and it's really good yeah it's it's
really good so we'll put a link to that
in the show notes as well let's move on
the right here right now where we talk
about what's going on in the lives of
the minimalist I've really been enjoying
this and I'm going to drag you on here
actually by the time this comes out
you'll have done a few of these with me
the living room conversations I have not
so on YouTube everyday I'm answering a
single question on YouTube let me just
say this I have not gotten this much
positive feedback about anything we've
done since our documentary oh that's
awesome I mean it people are like oh my
god keep
in this let me see you know like this
question hundreds of comments on the
YouTube comments
Wow asking questions and so cool
the day after recording this Ryan's
coming out to my living room we're gonna
record some some more living room
conversations and the thing I like about
is a really short videos they're like
two minutes to five minutes long like
it's just this little bite-sized video
of me in the living room answering one
question I brought back song from one of
about minimalist families and how do you
get your whole family on board with
minimalism I really enjoyed that one she
had her hair straighten so everyone was
saying that we look like twins which I
really do look like I'm realizing I'm
such a narcissist that I'm dating
someone who is just like me I'm
essentially having sex with myself
female version of yourself and it's
really good sex that is so funny oh no
oh you did a great job man yeah she
looks great but uh we we had a good
conversation but it was short you know
less than five minute answers to these
questions Ryan I'll come on there with
me as well what answers some of your
questions but that's there's gonna be 30
episodes total and then who knows we
might do one a week beyond that I have
no idea but youtube.com slash the
minimalist if you want to check out that
living room conversations find your
favorite questions and also leave your
questions there as well if you have a
question we'll answer some of our
favorites there that's where we pull the
questions from is from YouTube alright
oh by the way we're also hiring a
filmmaker because we're doing more of
these video things we're doing a video
version of the podcast which podcast
Sean is recording right now I have no
idea whether or not this is gonna make
it to the YouTube channel but we are
hiring a a filmmaker if it does though
it'll be a nice you know comparison to
when we do hire a filmmaker yeah we're
doing a single camera thing I see how
yeah how much better the production
quality will be yeah we're gonna go
ahead
oh I just want to say to anyone out
there who's like getting who's like
getting excited about oh man I can't
wait to like send in my submission and
please wait until we ask sending it
sending it to us on social media I love
the proactiveness but we need to have
everything in one place yeah so if you
send us something on social media or
send something to my personal inbox I
it's probably not gonna get looked at no
offense but we have to have everything
in one place right right so what oh good
well yeah it's just it's gonna be the
call first because there are a few
things we're looking for not much by the
way we're gonna be looking for you
what's your Instagram or Twitter handle
your name your phone number and then a
five minute demo reel so if you're
interested in that we're putting up this
job posting on the website on Friday
June 15 so that's this coming Friday
you'll be able to see the email address
where you're gonna send that off and
also what the requirements are what
we're looking for because you may be
really interested in and that's great
but you need to make sure that you can
fulfill the the requirements there's
some pretty basic requirements but you
need to be able to meet those in order
for it to even make sense for you to
submit anything and then that'll go on
for the rest of month the deadline to
submit your reo will be July 1st so you
can get started on it right now if
you're working on some sort of film reel
to really impress us that's great I
really appreciate the proactive and send
me a tweet on Twitter just say hey at
jfm really looking forward to submitting
this I like the I like the folks being
proactive on this absolutely but Ryan is
right and they all needs to show up in
one place and you'll have that email
address on Friday this Friday July the
I'm sorry June
that's a July June the 15th June the
15th is when the job posting goes up
June 15th the minimalists are hiring a
filmmaker what else do we have going on
here Oh new on patreon we just put up
the live Sidney event that was my
favorite event of the Australian tour
that we did back in March and this month
we're putting up the Melbourne event
which is Ryan's favorite event first
moment of it
yeah first moment we did Tina Melbourne
events yeah the first one which was
Ryan's favorite event of the Australian
tour plus we have 53 other private
podcast episodes so you get the whole
back catalogue if you become a patreon
supporter I already mentioned this but
we're coming to Kentucky Tennessee and
Alabama we're gonna be with Chris Hogan
we're gonna be with Rachael Cruz we're
gonna be with Anthony O'Neal talking
about money finances debt minimalism
decluttering and a whole bunch more
answering your questions Kentucky
Tennessee Alabama get your tickets over
at the minimalists comm oh and this is
the first writing class of the year and
I only do two of these a year I do these
writing workshops through our writing
workshop it's called how to write better
and do you want improve your business
emails write with more clarity or learn
how to write your first book basically
what I teach is
how to improve your overall writing I
believe the the rising tide lifts all
boats right and so if you want to
improve emails or text messages I've had
people literally take this workshop to
do that
or people say you know I'm been
interested in writing a book or I've
been interested in starting a blog I
don't know how to start and what I do is
I take the most important ingredients
out of my four-week writing class which
I know is too much for some people and I
tweeze out the important ingredients so
we talked about writing habits we talked
about writing composition we talked
about editing and then we talked about
publishing a different ways to publish
your work and we boil that all down into
a two hour online live workshop I also
do a Q&A at the end and if you can't
attend the live workshop its June 24th
then the video is posted in perpetuity
so if you sign up for it i limited 300
people because the QA gets a little bit
out of hand whenever we get above 300
people so if you want to be one of those
300 folks heading over to the
minimalists comm slash workshop you can
sign up it's called how to write better
it's a two hour online workshop a few
new essays over at the minimalists com
hopefully by the time this one comes out
I've been working on an updated essay
this new concept Ryan you and I have
been talking about a little bit
essentials non essentials and junk
mmm we used to call it need want like
and and it's sort of an update to that
but it's it's identifying the the things
in our life that are truly essential the
things that are non-essential but add
value and the things that are junk but
we pretend that value to our life and
it's good man because I often I find
when I'm trying to describe the need
once likes yeah I it doesn't translate
to everyone yes and I have to and we
have to explain here's what I need is
here's what I want is yours what I like
is rice is like so much more concise
yeah I think this will be really helpful
so you can find that over the
minimalists comm as well as all of our
other essays and and writings and
updates also the show notes to this
podcast if you want all that to show up
in your inbox all the new essays and
show notes just enter your email address
over at the minimalists comm and will
never send you spam cuz that stuff is
disgusting Ryan you got anything else
for us yeah man I got all these
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners you want to check them out
let's do it all right
this is Emily from Roma Park California
I was really moved by your collection
collecting episode and I wanted to talk
about how studying our history in
college I was very seduced by this
history of beautiful objects
I started collecting now at a young age
and just found it actually really
quieting for my mind to focus all my
attention on this one object and
studying it and appreciating its beauty
and it was only over time that I came to
realize it wasn't owning these things
that brought pleasure by actually just
feeling reverence for them and I was
able to sell my collections without
losing much money because in terms of
their value which sadly is not the case
with most objects in the world and now I
can move through this world of projects
and appreciate them and then just leave
them in the world the same way we take a
hike in the woods and we don't feel like
we need to bring home the trees and
rocks and creatures we just enjoy being
immersed in that environment and enjoy
it while we're there and I think too
often people think that when you're a
minimal if you have a kind of disdain
for stains and that you shun them and
reject them and that's just not the case
you can still very much enjoy objects
and be amused by the novelty goods at
the store or the beautiful jewelry on
people's wrists and you just don't have
to own it
so reverence is different than ownership
hey guys Bruce from Omaha Nebraska here
I was listening to the beginnings and
food and want to share something that
might add value to the lives of the
listeners looking to change their eating
habits as a sports nutritionist I'm
always looking to further educate myself
and recently I saw document on Netflix
called the magic pill it shines light on
some of the things that are negatively
impacting modern society's health and
gives great insights on the benefit of
eliminating processed foods and adopting
a diet based on vegetables and humanely
raised animals it's very well done and a
real eye-opener hello my name is Maggie
and I'm from Northport Michigan I wanted
to leave a comment addressing gifts I
recently saw a local news story about a
little girl who loved dogs so she asked
for birthday gifts such as dog food and
toys that would then be donated to their
local animal shelter so then I thought
for Mother's Day
you can ask for items that then could be
donated to the local women's shelter
also around Christmas there's usually
toy drives and winter coat and boot
drives and a last idea for children is
their classroom at school being adopted
to supply with some basic items that
their class could need all right Joe
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalists give us a
call for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9
you can also email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm right
from your phone and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus